[Musik]
kostbare Perlen pures Gold und
glitzernde Diamanten Schätze aus der
Natur doch der Abbau findet oft unter
Menschen unwürdigen Bedingungen statt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genau hier sieht man wogegen wir einfach
kämpfen die ganze Zeit weil das kann ja
einfach nicht sein und auch die Umwelt
zahlt einen hohen Preis dabei ist
Schmuck aus sauberen Rohstoffen möglich
wenn wir für die Natur sorgen sorgt sie
auch für uns
Juwelen und Edelmetalle werden zunehmend
in Laboren und Recyclinganlagen gewonnen
wenn man weiß wie es geht dann kommt
unten Diamant raus
wie entstehen sie die Glanzstücke mit
gutem Gewissen
[Musik]
die Region bussia im Osten Ugandas ist
bekannt für ihre großen Goldvorkommen
und doch ist die Bevölkerung nicht reich
seit Jahrhunderten holen Sie hier das
Edelmetall aus der Erde oft unter
unmenschlichen Bedingungen
[Musik]
die schmuckunternehmerin Guya Merkle ist
aus Berlin angereist nicht etwa um Gold
aus den Minen zu kaufen im Gegenteil sie
will dass das Schürfen hier ein Ende
nimmt
symbolisch ist es unfassbar emotional
und wichtig weil es wirklich die erste
Mine ist die wir jetzt einfach
zuschicken wir schütten einen aus der
noch Gold kommen könnte und das ist
einfach so abgefahren weil es ja
absolute Widerspruch steht ach mein Job
auf dem Weg dahin entdecken sie eine
typische Goldmine wie hier arbeiten
weltweit unzählige Arbeiter im kleinen
Bergbau unter und über Tage ohne
Ausbildung ohne Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
sie füttern die gesteinsmühlen mit dem
Erz aus der Tiefe
Minenbesitzer Simon ab der basi gewährt
der deutschen Zugang zu seiner mine
25 Männer arbeiten für ihn in zwei
Schichten für umgerechnet zwei Euro am
Tag
als die Schmuckdesignerin vor etwa zehn
Jahren das erste Mal mit eigenen Augen
sah wie ihr Gold gefördert wird änderte
das alles
genau hier sieht man wofür wir uns
einsetzen und wogegen wir einfach
kämpfen die ganze Zeit die Menschen
haben keine Schuhe an keine
Schutzkleidung die arbeiten hier mit
schweren Maschinen gehen da rein die
Erde ist auch super also es kann ganz
schnell quasi passieren dass es
zusammenbricht das ist schon
krass
in der Region finden sich viele solcher
kleinen Goldminen sie sind oft die
einzige Chance für die Menschen ihren
Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen das große
Geld machen die denen die Minen gehören
hi
naja hier wird dann gerade jemand
hochgezogen
was ist es ist kommt der Eimer auch hoch
zum Sitzen
schau du nimmst das Seil und setz dich
dort drauf
ich bin total fassungslos ich habe das
in der Art und Weise noch nie gesehen
dass es so tief runter geht und man
tatsächlich einfach an so einem an so
einem normalen Tau quasi in so einem
kleinen Joghurt bin runtergebracht wird
habe ich so noch nie gesehen ich habe
bis jetzt immer eher Minen gesehen die
quasi einfach breite Löcher waren aber
wo es nicht so tief rein gehen
die Schächte sind gerade mal einen
halben Meter breit und notdürftig mit
Brettern abgesichert in einer Tiefe von
ca 14 Metern verzweigen sich vier
Schächte in alle Richtungen
hier schuften die Männer zehn Stunden am
Tag und schlagen Erz aus der Erde die
Goldpartikel darin werden oben
ausgewaschen
[Musik]
das ist einfach unfassbar wenn du
einfach siehst dass diese braunen Steine
die unter den härtesten Bedingungen hier
rausgeholt werden eigentlich der der
Beginn von dem sind was wir machen
ich stehe hier ist es einfach
unfassbar
lebensgefährliche Arbeit unter Tage für
ein paar Gramm Gold und einen Hungerlohn
ich bin fertig
für ihre Schmuckkollektionen verwendet
Guya Merkel kein Gold aus Minen sondern
nur recyceltes
mit Anfang 20 erbt die heute 36-Jährige
Berlinerin das Unternehmen ihrer Eltern
und stellt die Produktion um
der Rohstoff für Ihren Schmuck stammt
aus alten Handys tonnenweise in Afrika
gesammelt und in Europa recycelt
eine Scheideanstalt löst in einem
aufwendigen Verfahren wertvolle
Edelmetalle aus Elektroschrott heraus
damit sie wieder verwendet werden auch
guyas Gold
doch die junge Unternehmerin geht noch
einen Schritt weiter sie will das Minen
in Afrika und Südamerika ihr schmutziges
Geschäft einstellen seit gut zehn Jahren
setzt sie sich dafür ein und heute ein
erster Etappen Sieg das halbe Dorf kommt
für den besonderen Anlass zusammen
[Musik]
Perlen die zu den seltensten der Welt
gehören
Jörg Gellner Schmuckmanufaktur im
württembergischen Wiernsheim steht für
Luxus pur
das sieht toll aus
ja
vielen Dank
[Musik]
55 Mitarbeitende Stellen Schmuckstücke
her deren wertvollsten Rohstoff für
Gellner persönlich einkauft 16.000
Kilometer entfernt in der Südsee
das war vor 20 Jahren noch anders
als die Firma übernommen haben wir noch
sehr viele chinesische Perlen gehabt
Süßwasserperlen ich habe dann aber
tatsächlich eben auch mal eine Farm in
China angeschaut und war dann
tatsächlich schockiert in welchen
Zuständen diese Perlen da gezüchtet
werden was für eine Überproduktion es
gibt wie immer Natur umgegangen wird da
werden Reisfelder einfach als
perlzuchtgebiete umgewandelt Flüsse wird
Wasser abgenommen sozusagen und
insofern haben wir uns eigentlich von
diesem Massenprodukt Süßwasserperle
komplett getrennt an den katastrophalen
Zuständen hat sich bis heute wenig
geändert in kürzester Zeit sollen
möglichst viele Perlen in einer Auster
heranreifen
die Schalentiere werden mit organischem
Abfall gemästet aus angrenzenden Hühner
und schweinemastanlagen
die überzüchteten Austern generieren bis
zu 60 Perlen nach der Ernte sterben sie
ja das klingt ja wirklich bestialisch
was auch ganz interessant ist was man
jetzt hier in den Bildern sieht dass die
Perlen ja an sich gar nicht weiß sind
sondern die werden chemisch behandelt
die werden gleich dass sie weiß werden
ja Gellner hat saubere Perlen gefunden
am anderen Ende der Welt
[Musik]
tropisches Klima kristallklarer Ozean
die Fidschi-Inseln im Südpazifik sind
ein Paradies mit einzigartiger Flora und
Fauna
unter der Wasseroberfläche verbirgt sich
eine tierzuchtfarm tausende von
austergittern an kilometerlangen Seilen
[Musik]
der Meeresbiologe und Naturliebhaber
Justin Hunter kennt die sensiblen
ozeanbewohner wie kein anderer seit 20
Jahren züchtet er die kostbaren Perl aus
dann die Pink tada Margarita das braucht
Geduld und Fingerspitzengefühl denn der
Anfang jeder Zuchtperle ist eine
Operation die Abend eine natürlichen
Prozess nach das Eindringen eines
Fremdkörpers in die Schale
wir wollen die Austern nicht zu sehr
stressen es ist natürlich ein Eingriff
aber wir versuchen sie so schonend wie
möglich zu behandeln
es sind lebende Tiere deshalb werden sie
nass gehalten schnell gewaschen und
gereinigt dann kommen sie erst in ein
erholungsbecken und anschließend zurück
ins Meer
der Japaner Matsuda dungalow ist der
wichtigste Mann in hunters Team er
operiert die Austern um die
Perlenbildung künstlich anzustoßen indem
er eine natürlichen Prozess imitiert
zunächst entnimmt er einer Spender aus
da ein Stückchen sogenanntes
Mantelgewebe zusammen mit einem
perlmuttkügelchen pflanzt er dies einer
Empfänger aus der ein
in ihrem Inneren bildet diese einen
sogenannten Perlsack um die Fremdkörper
ein Schutzmechanismus
darin ummantelt nun das Gewebe das
implantierte Kügelchen mit
perlmutt-schichten eine Perle wächst
daran
[Musik]
alle drei vier Jahre kommt hunters Kunde
Jörg gelner aus Deutschland nach Fidschi
und Perlen zu kaufen
gerade macht
er bereitet Implantationen vor
man sieht jetzt wie er den Kern
eingepflanzt hat man sieht es
manchengewebe wird um den Kern herum
wachsen und wird in zwei Jahren 2000
feinste perlmutt-schichten über diesen
Kern machen und die Perle ist dann
hoffentlich perfekt
ja das ist wirklich kein schneller
Prozess
nach der Operation kommen die Austern
für mindestens 18 Monate zurück ins Meer
oft für länger damit die Perlen in ihnen
heranwachsen können eine einzige pro
Auster nicht 60
fahren und schauen uns die Fahrbahn wo
die Perlen herkommen im Paradies
unser Team sammelt gerade die Austern
ein die in den nächsten zwei Monaten Ihr
Implantat eingesetzt bekommen
andere werden zurück ins Wasser gelassen
für die Ernte in zwei Jahren
und dann geht es zu den Austern aus
denen Jörg gellners neue Perlen geerntet
werden sollen
[Musik]
in diesem unauffälligen Industriegebäude
geschieht etwas schier unglaubliches der
Schweizer Fritz Walz schafft in seinem
Labor etwas für das die Natur viele
hundert Millionen Jahre braucht das sind
alles organische Produkte Liebesbriefe
Hundehaare
Pferdehaare das ist aus der Karosserie
von einem Formel E-Auto und das lässt
sich zu Graphit verarbeiten
Graphit ist der Grundstoff für das
edelste Gestein der Welt und lässt sich
aus allem organischen herstellen sogar
aus getrockneten Rosenblättern wie genau
das bleibt sein Geheimnis nur wenige
andere auf der Welt beherrschen die
vielen komplexen Arbeitsschritte
passiert du brauchst Druck und
Temperatur und das richtige Umfeld aber
wenn man weiß wie es geht dann kommt
unten die anderen raus
seit Jahrzehnten produziert Wald
synthetische Diamanten für die Industrie
inzwischen ist ihre Qualität gut genug
auch für die Schmuckbranche in der Natur
entstehen Diamanten im Erdinneren bei
enormer Hitze und gigantischem Druck
diesen Effekt erzielt eine riesige
hochdruckpresse innerhalb nur wenige
Wochen bei rund 60.000 Bar und etwa
1.800 grad den hohen Energieverbrauch
deckt Wald mit Solarenergie
[Musik]
für Schmuckdesignerin hellgemarin
Hauptmann aus Ulm sind seine Edelsteine
eine gute Alternative zu natürlichen
Diamanten denn ähnlich wie Gold werden
die oft im kleinen Bergbau unter
Menschen unwürdigen Bedingungen
gefördert
[Musik]
aus der Zelle nehmen ja
schauen wir mal was rauskommt
die Goldschmieden hat einen Stein für
einen Diamantring bestellt
ja und den lassen wir dann wieder in
Antwerpen Schleifen oder
ja genau
das ist auf jeden Fall für mich eine
super Alternative zum natürlichen
Diamanten weil in der Natur ist es ja
eben nicht nur der Diamant daraus kommt
sondern wir haben ja auch Abraum der
Wecker schafft werden muss wir haben da
natürlich die Flugstrecken die da auch
noch mit drauf gerechnet werden dann bei
so einem co2-abdruck rechnet man ja
alles was dazu kommt bei der Bearbeitung
die ganze Wasserverbrauch etc und da
sind eben die synthetischen im Labor
gewachsenen Diamanten immer noch
geringer es ist ein echter Diamant im
Labor gewachsen und der andere ist ein
echter Diamant aus der Natur aber sie
sind optisch
physikalisch chemisch nicht zu
unterscheiden
die Echtheit wird von unabhängigen
edelsteinlaboren zertifiziert drei
Wochen nach dem Schleifen ist das Juwel
endlich in Ulm und Goldschmiede in Helge
Maren Hauptmann kann den fertigen
Diamanten einsetzen und ein nachhaltiges
Schmuckstück herstellen
ich liebe selber nachhaltig vegan ich
versuche so wenig wie möglich CO2 zu
verbrauchen ich habe selber Ökostrom
hier im Atelier natürlich auch und so
mein eigener Leitsatz auch so nachhaltig
wie möglich zu sein und deswegen finde
ich passt es auch natürlich sehr gut
zusammen dass ich auch in dem Stil dann
arbeite
ein synthetischer Diamant kostet 30-40%
weniger als ein Naturdiamant die
Nachfrage steigt besonders bei jüngerer
Kundschaft wir haben ja das recycelte 18
Karat gelb Gold wir haben den
synthetischen im Labor gewachsenen
Diamanten dadurch schließen wir eben
komplett Kinderarbeit aus wir schließen
aus das in Minen gearbeitet wird also
die Umwelt nicht zerstört wird und ja
haben dadurch eben ein absolut
nachhaltiges Produkt
menschengemachte Edelsteine unglaublich
aber wahr
im ugandischen bussia ist der große Tag
gekommen das halbe Dorf strömt zusammen
aus Berlin ist Schmuckdesignerin Guya
Merkel angereist
jahrelang hat sie mit ihrer Stiftung
Earth Speed daraufhin gearbeitet und
heute feiern Sie einen ersten Erfolg der
das Leben vieler Familien verändert
ein denkwürdiger Moment
wir sind heute hier um die Mine
endgültig zuzuschütten meinen Club
sie ist eine Gefahr für unsere Gemeinde
wir haben etliche Menschen verloren
deshalb danken wir der Earth Beach
Stiftung für diese Initiative und hoffen
dass du weiter an unserer Seite bleibst
damit wir zusammen daran arbeiten dass
noch mehr Minen schließen
danke für Ihr Vertrauen und die gute
Zusammenarbeit
wir beten für die Menschen die wir in
dieser Mine verloren haben
einer war tabuccellis
ein anderer war ottschule Anton
emmokalodt verbeugen wir uns um für ihre
Seelen zu beten
möge der Herr ihnen Frieden schenken
sie wurden lebendig verschüttet dieses
Kapitel der Dorfgeschichte findet heute
sein Ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit zehn Jahren kämpfe ich gegen große
Widerstände an und es ist auch so ein
bisschen so ein was soll ich sagen so
ein geiles Gefühl auch zu sagen okay
krass das hat sich einfach so krass
jetzt frage ich doch an zu heulen
gelohnt dran zu bleiben
mit der Schließung einer Mine verlieren
die Bergleute ihr Einkommen doch dafür
hat sich eine Lösung gefunden
die nennen sie ihr flüssiges Gold
über die gesamte Bucht von Savu
erstreckt sich eine riesige
unterwasserfarm
schmuckunternehmer Jörg Gellner
besichtigt Justin hunters pernzucht es
ist Erntezeit
an den Stationen werden die Austern von
Parasiten gesäubert bevor sie an Land
gebracht werden
schon in der Antike waren solche Perlen
berühmt und besonders kostbar die
Perlenohrringe von Königin Kleopatra
heißt es entstammten dieser Muschelart
für mich ist es wichtig zu sehen dass
sie einfach ökologisch produziert wird
das sind Einklang mit der Natur ist
ja und es ist einfach ja das einzig
nachhaltige Juwel für mich was es gibt
die Perlenzucht verdankt ihre Schätze
dem Ozean die empfindlichen Tiere
brauchen eine intakte Marine Umwelt aber
sie leisten auch ihren Beitrag dazu
jede einzelne Auster filtert pro Tag
1.400 Liter Wasser wie eine Kläranlage
wo Perl Austern gedeihen ist das
Ökosystem im Gleichgewicht die
Artenvielfalt profitiert davon
das hier ist ein natürlicher Lebensraum
für viele Meeresbewohner vor allem
Jungfische Krebse und auch Seegurken
das nennt man Ökosystem Dienstleistung
der Fachbegriff für das was aus dann tun
sie ernähren sich indem sie Wasser
aufnehmen und dabei jede Art von Algen
entfernen die ihre Hauptnahrung sind
jeden Tag reinigen Sie also diese Bucht
doch über den Zustand des Ozeans wird
auch ein Land entschieden die
Bevölkerung auf den Fidschi-Inseln
wächst stetig aber mit der Infrastruktur
kommen die Kommunen nicht hinterher
Kläranlagen und Abfallentsorgung
beispielsweise reichen nicht mehr aus
vor einem Jahr hat Justin Hunter das
Blut town-projekt entwickelt sein Ziel
die Küstenorte sollen achtsamer mit dem
Meer umgehen an und von dem sie leben
lokale Unternehmen und auch der Stadtrat
sind inzwischen mit an Bord
blutdauen das Blut town-projekt ist eine
großartige Initiative nicht nur für
unsere Stadt sondern auch für die Dörfer
und ganz servus haben
das Blut town-projekt will Sabo Savu zu
einem Küstenort machen wo der Schutz des
Meeres neue Jobs schafft beim Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien beim Abfall
Recycling in Bildungsmaßnahmen und im
Ökotourismus
das Blut town-projekt will Umweltschutz
fördern indem es das Leben der Menschen
spürbar verbessert
Alessandro Rossi ist Teil des großen
Masterplans
der ehemalige Tauchlehrer betreibt eine
korallenaufzuchtstation und arbeitet mit
Justin Hunter zusammen
[Musik]
Korallen verbessern die Wasserqualität
die Lebensqualität im Ozean ganz
allgemein
Alessandro Rossi taucht in abgestorbenen
Riffen nach Überlebenden Korallen und
zieht sie groß in einer Korallen Farm
die er selbst unter Wasser errichtet hat
wenn Sie eine bestimmte Größe erreicht
haben setzt er sie an anderer Stelle
wieder ein viele Projekte wie dieses
tragen zu Justin hunters Initiative bei
[Musik]
und
Arbeit ist fantastisch es funktioniert
die Gemeinden machen mit
das ist der richtige Weg
und den verfolgt Justin Hunter Ziel
bewusst mit Unterstützung des Stadtrats
die Vision des perlenzüchters Savo Savu
soll in Sachen Umweltschutz ein Vorbild
für andere Küstenstädte auf der ganzen
Welt werden
unsere perlenfarm und die Ortschaften um
uns herum sind gewachsen
deshalb müssen wir den ökologischen
Verhaltenskodex an den wir uns hier bei
der Perlenzucht halten über die Grenzen
der Farm hinaustragen wir müssen eine
führende Rolle beim Umweltschutz und der
Verringerung der Verschmutzung einnehmen
auf seiner Farm erntet Justin Hunter
etwa 25.000 Perlen im Jahr es ist ein
Geben und Nehmen im marinen Ökosystem
servustavos Mensch und Natur im Einklang
wenn wir für die Natur sorgen sorgt sie
auch für uns es gibt einfach kein
anderes Produkt das der Umwelt mehr
zurückgeht ich liebe was ich tue ich
liebe wofür ich stehe ich liebe die
Umwelt in der ich lebe sie ist ein
großer Schatz das ist Leidenschaft folge
deinem Herzen
die Schätze aus der Sabo savu-bucht
werden geborgen zwei Jahre hat das
gedauert bis in dieser Auster eine
kostbare Perle herangewachsen ist ohne
das empfindliche Lebewesen zu verletzen
entnimmt der Operateur das kostbare
Juwel
[Musik]
der Wert der Perlen liegt zwischen 50
und 400 Dollar je größer desto teurer
[Musik]
der Stoff aus dem Träume sind dafür ist
schmuckunternehmer Jörg Gähner gereist
[Musik]
ja jetzt bin ich froh dass ich endlich
die Ernte anschauen kann
und hier haben wir die verschiedenen
Kategorien
das ist eine schöne Größe Justin 14 mm
eine Rarität ich liebe diese Farben hier
hat sich gelohnt um die halbe Welt zu
reisen weil es ist ein Privileg diese
Perlen zu kaufen da ist kein soziales
Leid in dieser Perle ist es einfach
komplett natürlich und ja zudem auch
noch wunderschön
mit 2067 fidschi-perlen im Gepäck geht
es zurück nach Deutschland
[Musik]
bussia in Uganda ist eine der
goldreichsten Gegenden in Afrika
seit Jahrhunderten leben die Menschen
hier vom Goldschürfen im kleinen Bergbau
schmuckhändlerin Guya Merkle hat es
geschafft eine der lebensgefährlichen
Goldminen zu schließen
[Musik]
eigentlich brauchen wir keinen kleinen
Bergbau mehr wir haben genug Quellen aus
denen wir Gold immer wieder in den
Kreislauf reinbekommen auf der anderen
Seite bedeutet es aber ja dass wir es
nicht mehr aus den kleinen Minen holen
die Menschen leben ja aber davon das
heißt wir müssen gucken wie schaffen die
alternative Einkommensquellen von denen
sie im besten Fall besser leben können
also auch ertragreicher mehr Geld
bekommen in einem sicheren Umfeld mit
nachhaltigen Methoden
hier sind wir
hallo Helmut Klatt schön dich zu sehen
willkommen
aus Minenarbeiter emoclott paul ist ein
Imker geworden und Honig sein flüssiges
Gold
heute braucht er einen Smoker Rauch der
die Bienen beruhigt statt einer
Spitzhacke
bei den Investitionen für Ausbildung
Schutzkleidung und Materialien half guja
Merkels Stiftung Earth speed
wie viel Honig erntest du
like
normalerweise ernten wir etwa 60 Liter
60 Liter pro Bienenstock oder von allen
von allen
Projekt läuft seit drei Jahren und
es läuft gut sonst werden wir jetzt auch
nicht hier und hätten eine Mine
geschlossen aber trotzdem ist es für uns
super wichtig dran zu bleiben also es
ist jetzt nicht sozusagen so ja das wird
schon weil es ist ja quasi die Basis vom
minenschiessen also wenn wir keine
Einkommensquellen kreieren können die
funktionieren dann wird natürlich das
Minen schließen auch nicht funktionieren
das heißt ich finde super wichtig auch
das Feedback zu bekommen das zum
Beispiel Anzüge fehlen um die Inspektion
zu machen nur wenn die Inspektion
gemacht werden können kann man mehr
schon emoklotz Vater züchtete Bienen er
selbst ging in die Mine zwei seiner
Söhne kamen darin um da waren sie noch
Teenager
die neue Arbeit beschert dem 85-jährigen
ein angenehmeres Leben
[Musik]
ist es ist ein sehr gutes Geschäft mit
den Bienen
man muss nicht bis zur Erschöpfung
arbeiten wenn du die Arbeit in den
Bienenstöcken erledigt hast gehst du
nach Hause und entspannt dann wartest du
drei Monate und kannst ernten so
verdient man Geld sauberes Geld ohne zu
schwitzen
inzwischen arbeiten rund 100 Menschen in
der Bienen Zucht Stadt in den Mienen und
es werden mehr denn die Nachfrage nach
Honig ist in den letzten anderthalb
Jahren stetig gestiegen die Imkerei
bringt gute Erträge und die Bienen
leisten obendrein einen wichtigen
Beitrag für das Ökosystem auf dem Land
[Musik]
für mich ist es total schön gerade auch
mit zu sprechen wir sind ja hier um zu
lernen also es geht ja um Partnerschaft
und das Feedback gerade von von jemandem
wie ihm ist Gold wert
bevor es zurück nach Deutschland geht
stattet guja Merkel den Minenbesitzer
Simon ab der basi noch einmal einen
Besuch ab
zu Beginn ihres Aufenthalts hatte sie
seine Goldgrube besichtigt sie möchte
auch ihn dazu bewegen sie still zu legen
und aus dem schmutzigen Geschäft
auszusteigen
und er zeigt sich tatsächlich
gesprächsbereit
ich bin tatsächlich guter Dinge trotz
allem was ich auch schockierendes
gesehen habe trotz allem was auch noch
nicht gut läuft wenn man es wirklich
schafft ein alternative aufzubauen das
hat er mir gerade noch mal bestätigt
dann würde er die Mine sofort schließen
ein Anfang ist gemacht Gold Perlen und
Diamanten macht eins noch wertvoller
wenn dafür weder Menschen noch Natur zu
leiden hatten Schmuck mit reinem
Gewissen ist kein purer
[Musik]